- I gave Zac a fake phone number.
- Yeah, he wasn't responding
to any of my texts.
Do I have your real phone number?
- No, not yet.
I refuse to give it to you.
(uptempo electronic music)
- I rescued a dog and he was a puppy and--
- He got away?
- He got away, but he knew
not to go a certain way
and I just ran out into
the yard to go save him,
so went right into the
street just in my underwear,
had just woken up and,
like snagged him and was like,
"No, don't run away," and I looked up.
My neighbor and his whole
family were like, "Morning."
I was like, "Hey.
"This is awkward, you have lots of kids."
(upbeat electronic music)
What style do the Real Housewives?
- Just like a angry, like huh.
I don't think I ever have had
an anger drink thrown in my,
I've had comedic drinks thrown in my face.
I don't think, I had someone, once a girl
flicked a cigarette in my face.
Also bad, probably worse than that.
- I was gonna say that's
potentially worse.
(upbeat electronic music)
- I've thrown, yes, I've
thrown a few parties
that have gone majorly out of control.
One time I threw a party
and I heard someone go,
"Holy shit, Seth Rogen's here."
And I was like, "Oh, man."
- (laughs) This is my house?
- Not what you wanna
hear in your own house.
(upbeat electronic music)
I've never actually won a dance battle.
- I don't know who ranks these things.
- Who wins?
- Yeah, at some point I jump
in and everybody gets excited.
- (laughs) And you win.
You're gonna win a dance battle.
- I guess I won, but
it's never like Step Up.
- There's never really a winner.
- Yeah, it's not like I'm
on stage with a bunch of--
- It's not like a definitive moment.
- Yeah, like standing on my hands
or spinning on my head.
- And everyone's like, "Woah."
The other team just like--
- Clapping.
And you end with the (grunts).
- Yeah, and everyone just knows--
- That you won.
(upbeat electronic music)
- Oh, I have for sure done that,
but I used to live next to a guy who would
have a lot of sex, whereas I did not.
You've heard it?
- Yeah, for sure.
Unless somebody's getting murdered.
- Yeah, unless it's a murder.
I always assume it's a murder.
(upbeat electronic music)
I didn't have a crush on him, but again,
my neighbor who fucked a lot seemed like
if that was my thing, he would
be a great dude to go after
'cause he seemed to have some
prowess in that department,
so he wasn't my
orientation, but if he was,
I would've gone for him 'cause
he fucked like a lunatic.
(Zac laughs)